qu'allah l'école texte corinne de
cloître illustrations et ce clé de sa
epsilon jeunesse 8 heures en arrivant
dans sa classe calmer son étiquette puis
prend de la pâte à modeler elle fait des
araignées du gross des moyennes des
petites des jeunes des bleus des rouges
d'un regard magique
elle leur ordonne d'avancé 9 heures cale
écoute la maîtresse qui ouvre grand sa
bouche et 10 avions aux ananas chocolat
je suis la marchande des as
je ne vends que des choses où l'on
entend un bonjour madame je voudrais une
banane lens il va moi je voudrais un
chat dit timidement lilly moi je
voudrais de la bave d'escargot un
margouillat des moustaches et un asticot
s'écrit call c'est pour préparer un
gâteau magique qui transformera en
princesse maîtresse 10h drire c'est la
récréation dans la cour
cal déguste son goûter préféré un gâteau
magique composé de bave d'escargot de 3
que de margouillats de 4 moustache de
chats et de petits asticots à sa
maîtresse
elle donne un morceau 11 heures cale
apprend à chanter une souris verte qui
courait dans l'herbe
sylvain son voisin rigole et dit qu'elle
chante comme une casserole la petite
sorcière lui lance un terrible regard et
le transforme en léopard midi cal
mangent à la cantine
elle boit un jus de bach badine et
grignote des scarabées
car elle n'aime pas le poulet une heure
cal va faire la sieste
sans demander son reste deux heures dans
son cahier call dessine son chat le plus
gentil des chats il s'appelle chat puis
sont rares le plus gentil des rats il
s'appellera et son araignée
porte-bonheur la plus gentil des
araignées elle s'appelle bien dessous
elle écrit chats rats et bien trois
heures c'est l'heure du sport les
enfants jouent au chat et à la souris
cal fait le chat est la trappe matteo
mater à léo et léa qu'elle transforme en
sourit puis la maîtresse raconte une
histoire
quatre heures c'est l'heure des parents
ta maîtresse ressemble à une princesse
qui la maman d'anne à pourquoi as tu des
oreilles de léopard demande la maman de
sylvain qu'est ce que c'est interroge le
papa de l'oea en tirant sur ses
moustaches hurle la maman de romain en
pointant du doigt une grosse araignée
bleus un peu à l'écart un ballet
s'impatiente
callen fourche et lui dit l'école c'est
abracadabrant